flawed nature is certainly not unique to
minneapolis
we are there but uh we are confronting
it hopefully very directly
yeah well truth lives in nuance and
unfortunately
you know media narratives are are driven
by kind of dualistic perspectives
on these things and i was reminded of
my own blind spots with all of this we
went uh to
i said this on a podcast the other day
but we went to
visit george floyd square yeah and after
seeing it on television a thousand times
i thought i had an idea of what it would
be
and what to expect and it was very
different
in every material way than everything i
imagined it to be
from the neighborhood to the setting to
the vibe to the people
everything about it was nothing like i
had imagined it
and i'd seen it a million times on
television and the reminder being
that you know just when you think you
have a grip on something
you really don't you know until you
experience it boots on the ground
and as being the leader of this city and
your responsibility to kind of
uh you know shepherd a real narrative
about
the actuality of the events that have
transpired and will transpire
what do you think like where is the
blind spot that the average person
living wherever
doesn't see or doesn't get about the
truth of the experience of living here
the the truth as you mentioned is always
nuanced
i mean you mentioned george floyd square
george floyd square is and has been both
this beautiful
place of racial justice and healing
a critical point where communities can
gather
and reflect and it's also true that
there are times that
that square in that area have not been
safe
[Music]
to ignore either one of those realities
would be to miss
the honest truth and it is true that you
know communities around there much of
them
black and brown communities have
suffered in some form due to some
upticks in violence
there's never unanimity of opinion there
certainly is not now
but i think in that case
i mean it's almost what george floyd
squares is emblematic of so many other
things that are happening right now
um in that you have these dualities
both of which are true you know
wonderful place for racial justice and
reckoning and
instances when it's it's not safe due to
other outside factors
policing we need deep structural change
to how our police department operates
we need safety beyond policing because
not every
call needs a response from an officer
with a gun
and we need police
there are horrible situations that we
make officers respond to that nobody
else wants to nor can they
yeah and both of those things are true i
think i think the
the police reform conversation is the
best kind of example to explore
how truth lives in nuance because it's
very easy to lapse into this notion that
with respect to minneapolis at least
it's either defund the police which
means a million different things to a
million different people
but it's often characterized as complete
abolition of the police or your
pro-military
militarization of the police it's an
either-or situation
and the longer that i'm here and the
more people that i talk to and the
deeper
i kind of educate myself about this
issue
it doesn't seem like there's that much
difference between
most of the voices who have a say in
policy making it seems that everyone
agrees that
the police need deep reform now there's
quibbling over
what that might look like or how that
gets implemented
but aside from
an extreme extreme fringe there's nobody
who's really saying we need we need to
abolish the police department completely
at least as far as i'm aware i don't
know you're shaking your head maybe you
can
tell me more about that and it's really
a conversation
about how to best accomplish this goal
that there seems to be somewhat of
a consensus on is that wrong or no i
think for the most part you're right
um following some of those most
tumultuous times after
george floyd was killed there were
definitely people that were calling for
getting rid of the police sure sure
whether we want to say
can we talk about the the video yeah
let's talk about the video yeah
so yeah i'm never gonna leave that one
down i mean
a lot of people probably who are
listening probably saw it but
uh correct me if i'm wrong it was in the
midst of a protest you were kind of
ushered out of your house and you joined
this procession
into downtown and in front of a large
number of people
a woman i forget her name uh sort of
publicly
asked you point blank in yes or no
fashion if you were
in favor of defunding the police and you
said that
if she meant abolishing the police that
no you did not support that
and that resulted in you being
essentially kind of
told to leave and you know shame on you
and all that kind of stuff and there's a
video of you kind of
walking through the procession of people
that a lot of people saw and that kind
of became
the lightning rod moment uh in terms of
how people were kind of contextualizing
this debate
yeah it was tough and let me tell you
i'm proud of that moment
i'm proud because i told the truth when
it was especially hard
um there's a large group as you
mentioned
of those protesting that came to my home
that demanded that i come out that were
asking for answers i came out of my home
and
i was asked to come up nearby the stage
area
and yeah i was asked if i would
be willing to commit there on the spot
to defunding the police
uh and i said very clearly that i am for
deep structural change of a system that
in so many cases has been racist
i think we need safety beyond policing
but let me ask you what do you mean by
that
defunding police and she said very
clearly i mean get rid of the police
and my answer is no um
because that's the truth
now the next day uh i'll note that there
was a strong majority in fact the veto
proof majority of the city council that
came back and took the same pledge that
i
refused to take and have since
almost every one of them gone back on it
um i'm not gonna say that i'm gonna do
something that i'm not going to follow
through on
and yeah it was tough um
i mean it doesn't tickle to get
game of thrones style shamed right in
front of the national media
but you know when i talk to black and
brown communities in our city
when i visit the north side which i do
all the time
there's a couple of comments that i get
the first is
thank you for immediately terminating
those officers
and calling for charges right there was
a unanimous praise for you
getting on that like immediately um
because
that has not been handled in that type
of fashion
in other instances in other cities
but the second thing that i hear from
our black and brown communities
is thank you for standing with our chief
and not agreeing to defund and abolish
the police
um and again no and so yeah so what do
you make of that
well certainly no community is a
monolith um
but if it's based on what i hear when
i'm out on the street if it's based on
what the polling clearly says
um it's dead in line you know our our
again no community is a monolith right
but what we hear loud and clear is that
they want deep structural change
do they want defunding uh no
and there has been some pretty
significant reformations
in terms of the police right with the
the the body cams and
the ending of the kind of warrior
training and a couple of other things
along with your homework i'm impressed
yeah yeah you know we've made some major
changes
um we
added a disciplinary matrix to our body
camera policy when i came into office
was about 55 compliance with our body
camera policy
um now there's 95 percent compliance so
in other words
before 55 of the time they were turning
on their body cameras right
and there's like a consequence if like
if that's not
if they don't turn them on when they
should there are
consequences to it uh the other
penalties
uh we were the first city in the entire
country to ban warrior style training
both on
and off duty we overhauled our use of
force policy we
banned no knock warrants for all but
exigent circumstances
uh we've ensured that de-escalation
would be added
and embedded in everything that our
officer is doing
by requirement and by the reporting
structure how it's set up
i mean i can go on there's a litany of
other changes that we've made
but here's the truth you know is that
going to change the culture
of our police department or any police
department no it won't these are policy
changes
yeah yeah so to what extent do they
fundamentally
alter anything or are they just
band-aids on a system
that needs a deeper kind of redress
i think they're important changes that
will help
but when you talk about deeper redress
let's be specific about what we're
talking about
um you know one of the things that i
think would make a huge difference is
arbitration reform
mm-hmm and i'll get a little specific on
this so we might end up just cutting
this part out but
you know this is a big deal and i think
every mayor every chief
is is hindered by
this these laws throughout the whole
country
when we when chief ardanta or i fire a
police officer
it is mandated that they go through this
arbitration system
that sees 50 percent of those
termination and disciplinary decisions
come
right back to the city so 50
of the time when we fire somebody that
decision is not upheld
because of this mandatory arbitration
that needs to change
yeah you know i think especially within
instances of egregious use of force
or uh lying on a formal document
that should change and you know there's
also a deeper
issue as well even beyond that um which
is
you know if you are an organization
that is known for being something you
know if
if you're a a podcast that is known
for attracting cool you know health
oriented
people with a good suntan you know
and then you go out and recruit
uh to get additional people to watch
your podcast who are you gonna attract
you know you that kind of
similarly if you're a police department
that is known for
something whether that's for being
compassionate and service oriented or
that's for being a bunch of racists
and you go out and recruit who do you
think you're gonna get right and so
it makes it all the more important that
you do this necessary work ahead of time
to change both the reality
and the perceptions so that you can get
the right individuals in
and then the wrong individuals out
[Music]
you